las historias humanas detrás de la
tragedia nos conmueven y aquí en makeen
está aquí vemos muchísima gente que lo
ha perdido prácticamente todo y un buen
ejemplo de ello son los que trabajaban
en la fábrica local de velas que ha
quedado reducida a escombros este es el
punto donde nos podemos acercar porque
hay trabajos de rescate ahora mismo en
funcionamiento el optimismo es poco
porque la devastación es tan grande que
realmente uno cuando ve cómo han quedado
los edificios las casas reducidos a
escombros es difícil imaginar que puede
haber personas con vida pero
evidentemente aquí nadie pierde la
esperanza pensemos que los que se están
acercando a sus casas para recuperar
objetos de valor y para ver lo que ha
quedado de sus viviendas realmente es
conmovedor ver el dolor que ahora mismo
impera en esta localidad de apenas diez
mil habitantes que va a tardar en
recuperarse